tennis star Serena Williams is
encouraging women to call the shots she
teamed up with bumble a dating and
social networking app that requires
women to make the first move a
commercial announcing the partnership
called the ball is in her court will
debut during the Super Bowl
we met with Williams and the co-founder
and the founder and CEO of bumble
Whitney Wolff heard we discussed the
importance of female empowerment and
what lessons Williams hopes to pass on
to our daughter Olympia the world tells
you to wait that waiting is polite and
good things will just come but if I
waited to be invited in I never would
have stood out
I think we're taught as women sometimes
that you know where's it's okay to sit
back and it's okay to to let someone
come to you and it's okay you'll get
your opportunity you can sleep well open
the door people will come to you but why
not just grab it and take it and be the
first and ask for it or go for our first
move what is the reaction been from your
peers in in the world of sports in
general that this is a conversation that
you're bringing to the forefront because
it's an issue that's affecting athletes
as well whether it's equal pay to equal
court time and show time it's just
really important for the new generation
to realize that listen we have to use
our voice and we have to we have to let
them know that we're just as good we
work just hard I know I've been working
since I was three years old you know
pick it up tunas racquets and so I
deserve the same treatment as everyone
else and most of all
don't wait to be given power because
here's what they won't tell you we
already have it you've got a great man
in your corner obviously that's me your
husband and you the family that you've
created with your beautiful little
daughter Olympia she's a year and a half
now what what is the world that you hope
she grows up then when it comes to this
issue in particular so I think our
messaging and things that we do today is
really helping our generation for
tomorrow which happens to be my daughter
and so that really kind of motivates me
to want to to speak louder and to do
more because I look at her precious
little face and I'm like oh my gosh I
wondered are the same opportunities that
if I had a boy he would have Whitney the
app itself and the idea of women being
empowered to make the first move when
you first had this idea did you get any
pushback and he blow back at all like
this is a bit too aggressive absolutely
and the pushback was what really
inspired this everyone was catering to
what the man might want and you had a
bunch of men sitting around saying well
what do women want we'll put one in
charge and maybe you'll find out Sarina
I'm interested in hearing your thoughts
on female athletes really trying to
break gender walls and play football and
other sports that have been dominantly
seen as male sports what is your
reaction to that what is your message to
these young girls well you have being
the first is never easy but it's really
like Whitney said is just really about
breaking down those walls and not giving
up and there's gonna be lots of nose I
can't tell you how many times I've heard
no and but eventually those nose will
become yeses but you can't stop you just
have to keep going yeah and it really
just seemed like a weight was lifted off
of her shoulders because she was a
trailblazer Sarina really when it came
to this issue and women speaking out and
really playing a dominant role in sports
and just in leadership in general and I
think now that this has caught on and
it's become part of the national
dialogue in the conversation I think she
finally feels like she can take a breath
and and now participate in a
conversation that she was at the
forefront of it's a great ad it's a
great ad I've said it before and I
firmly believe it the 21st century is
the century of women yeah
her daughter so cute and they both noted
that it's very important to have
supportive men there in your corner to
can't do it without men yes